はあああああ
[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーでず
はい止めずやりたいんですよ全然こういう動画やりたいんですけど僕が若かった時に
比べて最近は時間が
ってないあ時間がないんでちょっとあのんですね
なーんでまずカード取りたいんですよ子
おっられた時間かかるぞ取りたいんですけども取ることによるですねそれ
タイベル失うことが大きくてなかなかちょっと体力的にきついところあるんですけども
も今日はやりまそういうわけで私暖房時からポケモンを作る技術にとてもた気に入ると
自分しています今までですねメタグロスとべ r だとか何ボールで作ってきたんです
けどもう今回つけるポケモンはこちらえーっでクーザでございますレッグじゃあもう僕
の好きなポケモン
中でも結構上位に入るんですけどめっちゃかっこいいただダンバーでっていう時に
ブラシになるポイントとしてはエバー体の曲線美ですねこの身体の曲線美をどういう句
が凄い難しいかなという気はしておりますちなみにねメタグロス作った時は2日間出れ
ば作る時も2日間かかっております
結構積んでますいやもうこれ楽しいんだけどさぁ
作った山ボールでポケモンを作るために消えるの結構しんどいぜ
まあでも愛でなんとかしていきたいと思いますというデザインや九段ボールこちらです
まあ結構溜まってたんですけどもう締めのダンボールがかなりある気がしますそして
こちらが
裂空斬の色になる部分ですねベージュが緑なんでこういうのはすごく多くなると思うん
ですけども
口の中のあ
数のラインになる黄色メットカバーた袋が2位あるのでここらへん使っていきたいと
おもいまそまぁこんな感じですかね
早速ダンボールで空撮くっていきまっしょーかいてくる早速作っていきましょう
まずですねレッカーユーザーの好みでが入ってる導体のこの部分を作っていこうと思い
ますねこのペニーたパーツが胴体1
カラーんにしっぽさん尻尾44つほど同じくらいのサイズで君できればいいなと思って
おります作っていきましょう
このて大で加賀もだいたいお決まりますからね
うっ
me
ん
はし四つできましたはいこれがねクーザの中のこのちょっとポコってなっている4つの
部分にあたります
はポイントとしては足とかないのでその支えがないのであるべく体を軽量化した方が
いいかなと思いまして中身すべて空洞にしてて結構軽量化を図っておりますこれによっ
て実際のヘビでこういうなんか数になってもちゃんと自立するのかなと思い
ました次はこの身体の部分に釣れるものでブレードみたいなとこつけていきましょう
me
きっ
ん
me
始めてから約2時間が経過しました第六であのも告學疑ってきたんですけども同じよう
な作業が多いからちょっと今雑感心が折れそうですだいぶでで空賊子さんはもうだいぶ
出てきてるんで
あああん
[音楽]
同時ゲェーッ頑張りますかーっ
ん
ha
俺作ってて思ったんですけどこれからもこんなまま行くと相当でかいことになると思い
ます助けてください
いや前後のレックウザの目の部分にイベントお子様つけていきますされるべく軽量化し
てつけていきましょう
い
はいえーとですねレックウザの腕の部分の爪の白い紙デップがなかったねあのお掃除の
コロコロを使って作っていこうと思いますもうここらへんの発想が生まれながらに天才
だと思っちゃうよね
me
ok 導体の塗装完了ですこんな感じだと思いますね空団蔵たい
結構にべきだと思いたいんですけどハイディは続いて出てる次はしシッポ作っていき
ましょう
た
んをっ
これミスターん
はいじゃげで七宝後に完成しました回まだ全然体の一部なんですけどもシップは大体
こんな感じで完成だと思いますこの後はどんどんつなげて顔までいきましょう
だった弓くらい
初めて5週間が経過しましたそろそろ
酢味噌ですたいというわけで続いてはこの先のこの部分を作っていこうと思います
ちょっとカーブとか入れていきたいですねでもこっからぜもう丸めてあの蛇を作る
イメージでいいと思うんで結構適当な作業が続くと思います
tan
入ってみました体の部分です絶妙のカーブは歳月いたなと思いますそれをつけていき
ましょう
これ
ねっ
わー
これむずいな連結作業はめっちゃくちゃうですこれまだ反面も言ってないんですけど
だいぶならいいですねこれでっ気座の長さは変わり最低てきてるかなと思います
手続き頑張ってきます
ん
えっ
やばいデカすぎるよやばいよ
これでようやくたか半分くらいです
でガーッ
rar
ん
シャアこれだシャアこちらをつけていくんですけども
こっから上に向かってわかんなきゃいけないんで結構かなり重いと思うんですよなんで
骨組みとしてまずこれを入れて確実に上に向くようにして当たっ今なめらかにして蛇
っぽい曲線をつくってこれをかぶせて顔を作って完成です
はいというわけで顔以外はできました
もうそこもずっと続いてる
やばいでかいですちょっとそう思っていたサイズの2倍ぐらいの長さになってしまった
んですけどもまぁドラゴンポケモンということで結構時間ってこんなもんでいいかなと
思っております
いただいますじゃねえええ
レックウザ作り始めてから8時間が喧嘩しました
を配膳最後か音くん頑張ってかっこいいかをつくってかーっ
me
ん
よっしゃとは
グレードをつけて終わりだ
me
はい篠山の地獄朝の9時
ベック座を作り始めて
分かりません続ないだろう
8時間半かな8時間半が経過してようやく最後の作業
レックウザにある4つの都合次で終了です
わざわざんちょっと何も考えませんとりあえずつきます
ん
me
大丈夫でっクルーザーの顔です招く the 唇がちょっと特徴的なんでますそこさえ
赤くひときわなんかまりとそれっぽくなるかなと思って作ってみました
お盆に入り大変お待たせいたしましたでは最後にレックウザのかを簡単に付けていき
たいと思いますもう
ほぼ9時間掛かっんいきまーす
ben
いやぁー
ちょっと見ていきましょういやもう完全に裂空斬よコーンちょっと高校は申し上げない
こうをしないとで立たない千段ボールの力だと骸骨からの顔完全レッグズじゃないかな
と思います相手で9時間かけてダンボールでレックざー
作ってみましたあのー死ぬほど疲れた
プチがノートパ
1ゴールでつくるのマジ使えますからねーなー
お家行って良かったですもうめっちゃ達成感があります相手だけど本当にあの僕も時間
だったらこういう道がたくさん取りたいんですけど私になって忙しいで7高1日に動画
にすべて捧げるって事が出来なくて
まま久しぶりにちょっと本気だしたら
こんなもんかないだけなんですね楽しかったすただ皆さんこれで僕は徹底をしてしまっ
て脅威政治を割ってしまいましたありがとうございました
またないが時間ができればこういうことやってみたいと思うので是非皆さん二木の
ポケモンでお会いしましょうバイあ違ったおやすみ
[音楽]
me
バッハ